right here we're seeing the the the
matchmaking we have a update to the
matchmaking where everyone when will
gray out and when it'll you'll gray out
until you're actually match made and so
it'll also auto balance so when you're
seeing this screen right here when it's
all gray it's basically thinking it's
trying to put together the best match
the best game for you and then once it's
done it'll lock it in two colors and
then some some Titan customization that
we added so we added insignias
unlockable insignias one of the one or
the ones i don't know if you remember
the gooser challenge it got a little out
of hand it was like 50 is kind of a
crate I don't know what their it was a
good challenge yeah so we dropped it
down to five but for the people who
completed those 50 they can throw an
icon for their own decal basically you
select these I caught these decals you
unlock them like here's one this gen 10
and they'll I just saw it in your you're
recording but when you go like on the
Titan they're kind of placed
strategically in spots where they make
sense where you can see them like the
rodeo hatches have them they'll be on
the front of the Titan so just another
it's a little detail that you can kind
of personalize your Titan a little bit
with then we've got the we've added
Betty is the voice that you used to
hearing inside the Titan cockpit but
we've also added Lisa you'll hear it
when I selected here you'll hear her
speak and then we've got your scores
ready so let's just add another little
layer inside there
then one thing that I love got really
excited about you go to last something
that was like really needed we did a
little update on this screen but you can
go over to you can see your score board
now which is something that we didn't
have in before we just updated it so all
this stuff will be updated by the end of
the month I look at pushed out to
everybody for free the only DLC the
that's paid for is new maps and so we've
got the first DLC pack out now we've got
two more are that are coming the new
moda we're showing today is marked for
death it's a 66 match you drop into the
match player on each team is marked for
death randomly and the goal of the game
is kill their mark before they kill
yours protect your mark once a mark is
eliminated it switches marks for both
teams and you just go from there it's
really awesome good plater a good way to
rack up pilot kills yeah that modes for
everybody it's a it's a big update by
the end of the month pc xbox one and i
think the 360 kind of is going to be
right behind us on that stuff they're
just kind of a little bit like a little
bit of a buffer and then we're not we're
not showing it today but there's we're
doing a to be true it's called wingman
last time to standing except of to be to
match it's very like Titan tactical